- Good afternoon, everyone.
On behalf of
The Council on Latin American
and Iberian Studies (CLAIS),
let me welcome, especially
on behalf of her director,
Claudia Valeggia and her
team, she couldn't be here.
And especially to this fourth event
of the Latin American
Policy Leader Series.
My name is Jessica Faieta.
I am a Senior Fellow at
the Jackson Institute of Global Affairs
and lecturer on
Development Issues in Latin
America and the Caribbean.
And today I have the distinct pleasure
and honor to welcome our
speaker María-Noel Vaeza
the Regional Director for
Latin America and Caribbean
in a very important institution
of the United Nations,
UN Women.
It is a particular pleasure
because María-Noel and I
are colleagues from the United
Nations for the longest time.
I have been in the past
before coming to Yale,
30 years in the United Nations
and a big part of this,
we have been colleagues with, and friends,
good friends with María-Noel.
And both we have worked in
Latin American the Caribbean.
We have coincided in many ways,
most recently when I was
Assistant Secretary-General
and Regional Director in the region.
So I can attest the firsthand that,
of her knowledge about
the region, her expertise,
but most importantly, her commitment to,
in this case, to the advancement of women.
So she is really fantastic
guest for this policy series.
The title of her talk is,
"Diversity, Equality and Gender."
And I think you will agree with me
that this subject is particularly relevant
to reflect on this, not only
in Latin America and Caribbean,
but I think even in the country
that we are right now holding this.
And of course in Yale
University where this subject
is also of great interest
to the students and faculty.
We hope that today's
event will provide a forum
for discussing the role of
organizations such as UN Women
to, for the advancement
of diversity and gender.
The Latin American Policy Leaders Series
is organized by CLAIS,
seeks to create dialogue
about the future of democratization,
human rights, and development,
with policy leaders
from across Latin
America in the Caribbean.
With this initiative,
CLAIS hopes to engage
leaders from the region
in vigorous and respectful discussions
about pressing issues,
while also benefiting from
their years of experience.
So certainly it's an
honor for me to be invited
to host and to moderate
the talk of Maria-Noel,
as she possesses the
right kind of experience
that we need to hear right now.
So let me tell you a little
bit about María-Noel.
She assumed her functions
as Regional Director for the
Americas in the Caribbean,
in UN Women in 2019, but
before that, she worked as
the Director of the Program
Division at headquarters.
And she joined from another
UN organization, UNOPS,
where she served as
the Director for Global
Portfolio, and before that
Partnerships Practice and
in Strategic Partnerships.
So she has a long and distinguished career
in the United Nations.
She also spent eight years in UNDP,
where she held various posts,
including a Senior Advisor,
Deputy Resident
Representative in Paraguay,
and Senior Manager
for the Recovery, Reconciliation
and Reform Program.
She also has a distinguished career
in public service in her own country
because prior to joining
the United Nations,
María-Noel held multiple positions in
Uruguay's Ministry of Foreign Affairs,
including as Political Counselor
at Uruguay's Embassy to the United States,
and as Delegate of Uruguay
to the UN General Assembly.
She also was an alternate
Representative of Uruguay
to the World Bank Board of Directors.
María-Noel is a national from Uruguay.
She holds a Doctorate of
Law and Social Sciences
from University of the
Republic of Uruguay,
and she also has a Master's Degree
in International and Public Policy
from Johns Hopkins
University in Washington, DC.
The structure of today
is something you have
already are familiar with.
She will have her talk.
We will then follow with
some moderated discussion,
which you are invited to raise your hand.
And I am particularly
welcoming all the people,
all the students and faculty
who are, and public in general,
who are joining us right now on online.
Before turning the
microphone to our speaker,
I would like to thank the
sponsors of this event.
The Latin American Policy Leader Series
is generously supported by the
George Herbert Walker Jr.
Lecture Fund in International Studies
at the McMillan Center
for International Studies.
And this event would
not have been possible
without the assistance
of the collaborators,
such as the Office of
International Affairs,
the Fox International Fellowship Program,
and the Program for Peace and Development,
and if I may also add,
the Jackson Institute for Global
Affairs, to which I belong.
Thank you to the staff and the colleagues
who made this visit possible,
and without further ado,
María-Noel, you have the floor.
(audience applauds)
- I feel so old every time I hear my CV,
(general laughter)
It means that I've been
around for some time.
Thank you, Jessica.
It's a real pleasure and honor to be here
and also being introduced
by such a distinguished
colleague as Jessica.
We've known each other
for a long time as well,
but Jessica has been a
leader in our region.
And also we are very happy to see
that that she's here in Yale.
I think that we practitioners,
we have something to say and to transmit,
but it not always happens
that we have this opportunity.
So I'm really grateful for
Yale and for the faculty,
for all the colleagues
that has been so kind with
me since I arrived yesterday.
So thank you so much for
giving me this opportunity.
For me, it's very important
to bring to your attention,
what is UN Women?
What are we doing?
and why it's important to
focus on women's issues.
And women in all their diversity,
because we are not, you
know, the same women.
That's why the concept
of intersectionality
is so dear to UN Women.
So I would like to start by saying,
what do we do in, well,
I dunno, it doesn't work,
but I would like to, to share with you,
what is the situation of equality,
of gender equality, and on
gender inequality as well.
But what are the key areas of UN Women?
Where do we work in the region
and how do we see gender
inequality in our region?
And what are the solutions
that we are proposing?
Because we try to focus in
certain solutions before,
you know, instead of being everywhere,
we try to focus and try to
move the needle as we say,
and try to change the reality of women.
So we do three things,
basically in our mandate
from the general assembly,
we were created 11 years ago.
We are really young for the UN.
And we were created as a
merge of several institutions
that were dealing bits
and pieces of gender.
And it was a very intelligent decision,
I must say, from the general assembly,
because we could really
merge the specialization
that were in the UN everywhere.
And we had the opportunity to have
our first Executive Director
was Madam Michelle Bachelet,
the former President of Chile
and right now she is the High
Commissioner for Human Rights.
So it was a real honor
to have her with us.
I was not in UN Women at that time,
but I was envious of
the UN Women colleagues
because they had such a
distinguished executive director.
And we decided at that time
that we should focus our attention
on women political participation,
women in the public space,
on women economic empowerment,
the autonomy of women,
because we really are half of
the population of the world,
but we are not contributing to the economy
as half the population of the world,
and that's why the world
is not growing enough,
because we are not enough participating.
And of course, violence against women,
which is the biggest, I would say,
shadow pandemic that we have
that came more in light
during the pandemic,
because it was obvious
that this was a big issue
that everybody needed to attend.
And of course we are
universal. We are global.
So women peace and security
is a very important part of our work
and the humanitarian
response of what we do
in that parts of the world.
But, you know, I didn't know
when I came to Latin America,
when I came back to Latin America,
that the region was going to
be in such enormous problems.
I thought it was a nice position to be,
to really establish innovation,
to try to work differently
from other UN agencies
and, you know, calmly integrate our work
and gender perspective in the work
of the other UN agencies.
And suddenly we have
social unrest everywhere.
It was Chile, it was Bolivia,
it was Ecuador, it was
Colombia, it was everywhere.
And it was a really a boost of energy
coming from the women's movement
because it started on the 8th
of March in Santiago, Chile,
and then in continue to uprising
in the indigenous population in Ecuador,
but it was women's movement,
indigenous women's
movement that were behind.
And of course, then we have it in Colombia
and Bolivia was in chaos
because of the coup-d'etat,
so it was everywhere.
And I said, "What is
going on in my region?"
I thought we are overcoming
the governance issues."
But it wasn't and it didn't,
and it's a big question mark.
What is gonna happen with our governance?
What is gonna happen with gender equality?
We have only one president
who declare himself feminist,
which is Boric, the President of Chile,
but rapidly he's losing popularity.
And so he doesn't even have a hundred days
and he's already been a pariah
in many aspects in his country.
And we have the
constitutional reform in Chile
that is also a beacon of hope,
how the women's issues are gonna be,
you know, in the constitution.
So here we are trying to attend all this
and suddenly the pandemic came,
but we knew that 74%
of who was in the front lines
of the pandemic were women,
but only 20% of women
were at the forefront
of the decision making.
So there you start seeing
the gap, the discrimination,
and the lack of understanding
that women have also a say,
and they have a say
that perhaps is innovative, is different.
You can only look at how the leaders,
11% of the leaders of the world are women.
And if you see those countries,
those countries managed
the pandemic very well.
Like the prime minister of New Zealand,
the chancellor of Germany,
the prime minister of Norway, of Finland.
So there is a common thread
that women perhaps has a
different way of leadership,
of making sure that everybody
is in the table before taking decisions,
listening more, and of course
we don't know everything,
so we need to consult.
So perhaps this kind of leadership
with these soft skills that
we call them, you know,
is what the world needs right now
to really confront several
crisis at the same time,
like the pandemic brought the into light.
So for us in Latin America,
it has been a horrible consequence,
the pandemic for women.
We were a region
that was growing the participation
of women in the economy
and the pandemic stopped
that, very much so,
and now we went back 18 years,
we went back 18 years because
of one reason, which is care.
We women are the main care providers.
And suddenly the world realized
that care is very important
because most of the COVID patients
were at home being care by whom, by women.
So care came to the front
lines and care came as saying,
"This is an unpaid care work
that we do more than everybody else."
So we have weeks of eight days
because our work is to care
and our work without recognition,
without redistribution,
and without reduction
of the unpaid care work.
And unfortunately, although we thought
this was going to be changed
in the pandemic, it didn't.
Women continued to do
three times more care,
unpaid care work than men.
And in some countries, we
did surveys like in Chile,
it increased the unpaid care work of men,
seven minutes, seven minutes!
When we had the children at home,
when we had to be there
for them for the education,
when we had to take care of elderly,
take care of the children,
it means that men are
not being co-responsible
of the household, of the
education of children,
of taking care of their own elderly,
because normally women take
care of their own elderly
and the elderly of their partners.
So unfortunately this requires
the attention, not just from,
from us as UN Women, the UN system,
but also from civil society,
from governments, and particular
from the social media.
I think the power of the
social media right now
give us the opportunity to
really change this behavior of
and understand that without
the co-responsibility of men
in the household it's impossible for women
to really thrive and participate.
And that's why women
are not searching actively
for jobs in my region,
because they have to stay
home and provide care.
This is why my number one priority
with all my colleagues in the region,
we are 550 gender experts in the region,
in 26 countries, so we
are quite a crowd there.
And we decided to focus our attention
on systems of care, the society of care.
We will have the Regional
Conference of Women in Argentina,
on the first week of November,
second week of November,
we have this regional conference
for the last 45 years,
is in the family of ECLAC, is
intergovernmental conference.
The first one was in Havana 45 years ago
so it means that this is an institution
that we need to preserve.
And the subject is Society of Care,
not just the care of people,
but the care of biodiversity,
the care of climate.
So for us establishing
integrated system of care
that integrate not just
the federal levels,
the sub-national levels,
the municipal levels,
but private and public,
and also community level
because indigenous population,
they do care in a different manner
that we need to integrate.
So that's what we are working.
We are working 12 countries
to establish the legal framework,
to establish the costing.
How much it cost to the government
to finance a care system.
That it is an investment
because we always say that
it has three dividends.
The first dividend is
the care to the family,
the welfare of the family
because when you have an
elderly, a sick person,
a disabled, kids, very small kids,
when you have professional support,
everybody will be happier
and particularly the woman
that is doing the care, unpaid care.
The second is for the economy,
because there is a creation of jobs
that is very important
and is a green economy,
is, they call it the orange economy
because it's not polluting,
but you are giving the opportunity
to those women that are
working in the informal sector,
normally as domestic workers,
you have to give them
the opportunity to study,
to do a certification,
and to really go out there
and be caregivers, more professional.
So we reckon that this will
create millions of jobs,
and it will dignify
the women that are working
in informal sector,
that don't have benefits,
that don't have anything
except the little salary
they receive, when they receive it.
Because in the pandemic, we saw that they,
some of them were slaves.
They were not allowed to leave the houses
because of the contagion.
And we believe that those
jobs will be paying for taxes.
So the system that we are
trying to create everywhere
will pay by itself.
There is an initial investment,
but then it will be paid by itself
by the creation of jobs
in the care economy.
And the third dividend is for women
to have the opportunity
to go out and work.
And of course, get out of
poverty, because the moment
the women have subsidies to for care,
or the women can provide
proper care for their own,
they, she goes to work
and of course she will invest
back in their own family.
So for us, that's a priority,
together with financial inclusion.
So we will, we are trying
as well to make sure
that the different
investors, banks, you know,
crowd funds, venture capital,
is you name it, fin techs,
everybody, have a special
consideration of women
because unfortunately we
are only 11% of targets.
So this is not possible
that 89% of the funds
are channeled to men.
We need to change that reality
and for that, we open up a platform.
And what we are trying to
do is to bring everybody
and we call it the Platform
for in Gender Investments.
And there are three things that
for me are essential there.
One is, those are investments
that are gonna yield very
positive desire, the results.
You're gonna make money
by investing in women.
And also you are given the opportunity
to those companies or entrepreneurs,
that are trying to get out of,
of their micro-enterprise
learning, lending
that is all well and good, but
you never get out of poverty,
to scale up their entrepreneurs,
entrepreneur objectives,
and really, you know,
provide this opportunity
to women to thrive.
And the third for me, which is essential,
is the impact of the social investment,
because you are not
only investing in women,
you're investing in the community
where women is uncertain.
And for that, we have seven
principles that we call it,
the Women Economic Empowerment Principles,
that help the private sector,
and the private banks,
and the private capitals,
to understand that this is
not just one investment;
this is an overarching framework
to be successful for an investment.
And then of course, women
political participation
is still for us very important.
We have only 32% of women in parliament,
but we have very important
examples of parity in all,
like it was in the last
elections in Mexico.
It was a political decision to say,
let's have election parity in everywhere:
governors, municipal
level, the parliament.
And this is working very nicely,
it's a lab of parity in the world.
And then Bolivia that
declare parity many years ago
and we still have 51%
of women in the Senate.
So this is also very nice.
And also Costa Rica, Argentina,
there are countries that they have worked
through different laws, you know,
how to get to parity or to quotas.
But the rest of the region we are still
quite low in women
political participation,
not just in the parliament,
but also as mayors.
We have only 15% of women
mayors in Latin America,
15% is nothing.
Of course, we have Mexico City.
We have Bogota, which are
enormous cities, but anyway,
you know, we need to push
women more at the local level.
And for us also,
it is important too, actions
at the public sector,
which is the gender responsive budget.
The national budgets are still
the most important development instrument
that a country has,
but it doesn't have a gender lens.
So we really need to work
different methodologies
to push for gender budgets,
and gender planning,
and gender statistics, et cetera.
What you don't count, it doesn't exist.
And most of the time women
are completely invisible
and women of color
or women of indigenous descent or LGTBI,
they are completely invisible.
So we need to work
on those statistics to
bring them to the light.
Then women economic
empowerment, as I was saying,
the economy of care
and financial inclusion
are the things that we have prioritized
because we believe they need the most.
And of course, violence against women.
Violence against women is a
horrible problem that we have.
If you can think in Mexico,
there are 12 women that,
that dying a day, just for
the sake of being a woman.
So we really need to,
and we have more like
4,000 feminicides a year in the region.
So those are buried data
that we need to change the reality.
And how do we change that?
By changing legal frameworks,
by making sure that we have the data,
because it's very, you know,
it's very scattered the data.
So we really need to,
and to have, you know,
centers of care, centers
that can care women
when they are first being
victims of violence, right?
So this is what we normally do.
We work with the framework,
we work with data,
we work with integrated,
integrated different
inter-agencies response
that government has, et cetera.
And then of course, for us,
it's essential to understand the financial
of those gender programs.
And we are pushing for
STEMs, women in STEMs.
We don't have enough
girls, or adolescents,
studies, the careers of the future,
or the career of the present,
so we need women in technology,
that's why we have several initiatives
to introduce women to technology,
to science, et cetera.
We are still only 30% of
women that are studying
or working in the STEMs
area in the region.
So, and the last point
for me will be democracy,
governance, social unrest,
and all the things that
we have been watching
all around in the media,
but also the lack of opportunity for women
to be in the decision making tables
and to bring their own perspective,
which is different from
men, but also the solutions
because women have very
important solutions.
As mothers, as you
know, community leaders,
they can see things in
a different perspective
and they can help
governments and civil society
and private sector to bring
a different perspective
and a different human
development, if I may say.
So I would like to stop there
and thank you very much for listening and,
and I'm here for answering any questions
and receiving recommendations as well,
but thank you so much.
(applause)
- Thank you, María-Noel,
can I invite you too?
- Okay.
- To sit here so we can
now have a conversation.
- Ooh, is this comfortable!
(general laughter)
- Thank you very much.
You have given us really a,
a very sobering, I think, situation
on what is happening in Latin
America and the Caribbean
with regard to diversity,
to the situation of women.
But I also found it very encouraging
that you are working
and focusing on very specific solutions,
especially when you
talk about the systems,
integral systems of care,
and also empowering of women
with very clear solutions going forward.
Let me open for some questions
before I have some questions of my own,
but I'd like to give the
opportunity to the students
and also to the public who is connected
to give us some questions.
So anybody that has some
questions, please raise your hand.
Well, while they get, well,
the, oh, here we have, please.
Please introduce yourself,
from what school you are,
what year, and go ahead
with your question.
- My name is Daryl, I'm a
first year Master's student
at the Jackson Institute.
I was wondering, I was wondering,
were there any thoughts about paying
just women just for
being at home in general?
So you mentioned having
care workers come in
and allow women to go out and work,
but paying women for the
work that they already do.
Was that like any policy
discussions around that or?
- Yes. Thank you for your question.
And yes, indeed.
In my country Uruguay,
it exists sort of a payment
for staying home mothers.
And it's a, it's a subsidy.
I wouldn't like to call it subsidy
because if you analyze the
time that women spend in care,
it could get to 20% of the GDP.
We did that study in
Mexico, and in Colombia,
and it's much more than oil
and minerals than everything.
So it means that the
development of the country
is in the shoulders of women.
So this is a payment that the government
of Uruguay, Columbia,
Panama, Argentina,
they decided to do to women
to stay home and care.
And it's working very nicely
because some of the women are saying,
"I'd rather stay home than be out there."
And what we notice is that we did a study
some years ago about the pyramid of women,
the women that are in
the bases of the pyramid,
women that were mothers,
because they were raped at 15 or 16 years,
they are very poor.
They don't, they haven't
finished their education,
those women if they
want to go out for work,
they have to indebt themselves
to get a care provider.
So we have internal debt of
the most poor of the women,
because there isn't a system of care
that can allow them to go to work
and to get out of poverty, or
go back to study or et cetera.
So for us, this has been something
that we really brought into the attention.
There are some women
that want to stay home,
they need to have that payment,
but there are some women that
they want more from life,
they want to continue studying.
So we really, when we provide the,
I would say the technical
assistance, we put all this.
So we were discussing
with the Minister of a
Social Affairs of Chile
on this respect,
to map how many women are,
how much this is gonna cost.
So we create a different
methodology of costing
of the different care,
you know, care provider,
the person that wants to stay
home, how much the payment,
but we should pay attention to
the time that women uses
on a daily basis for care.
And that has a value.
And it's more valuable than
any industry in the country.
But yes, this is part of our toolkit
of advice to governments.
- Please.
- Hi, my name is Brianna.
I'm a graduating student
at the Jackson Institute
for Global Affairs.
I'm also Mexican and I worked
last summer with ECLAC,
helping them plan their
original conference for women.
My question for you is how
to foster political will
in the political climate
that is going on right
now in Latin America,
incentivize these
governments that right now
have so many needs to cover
to make that initial investment in women,
how to convince president,
how to convince the ministers of finance,
to listen to the ministers of the women
and invest money in care systems?
- Thank you for your
question, muchas gracias.
Well, we are trying to convince them.
And last Sunday, the
president of Argentina,
and Argentina is in a big,
big trouble economically,
he announced that he was signing the law
for creating the care system
and he put it as an investment.
Well, we did the talking points.
(general laughter)
I can, I hope it doesn't
get out of here, but,
(general laughter)
but it was a convincing,
not just from the minister of gender,
but also from different
arguments, economic arguments.
The meeting we had with
the minister of economy
was pure economic value of
investing in the care giving.
And I remember his face,
he looked at us and said,
"Okay, I will, I accept that."
So when you bring numbers,
when you compare industries,
we did a study in Turkey
together with UNDP
and the University of Ankara
to compare the infrastructure
sector and the care system
that we wanted the ministry
of finance to invest.
And he was convinced
with the sheer numbers.
And I guess that we people
who work in development
and with gender issues,
normally we are seen as,
you know, the crazy
feminists that go and march,
and we are not that.
We are that, plus!
(general laughter)
And I guess that,
but continue the studies
and deepening the study.
That's why I'm so happy to be
here because it's so important
that academia takes the
focus out of the agenda
that is a traditional agenda of gender,
which we need to continue
because human rights is
super important for us,
and we have to put it at the center,
but we also have to analyze, you know,
these things that I'm saying about
getting the autonomy of
women, economic empowerment,
because I am convinced that
the more autonomy a woman is
the less likely she will
be a victim of violence.
So I think that things are related,
and also she will have
the leadership skills as
well to become a politician.
So, I mean, I tend to be
romantic and believe in all that.
- It's, is good to be romantic in,
especially because we need
people who are convinced of this.
And I think I cannot
think of better colleagues
than UN Women to pass this passion.
I want to ask you a question of my own
while, you know, students
think of other questions.
You mentioned about the importance of
investing in women's projects.
We have some students from
business schools, right?
And of course at the end of the day,
not, nobody's going to invest
just because they are women's project,
they need to be, as you
said, good business.
- Yes, yes.
- So tell us a little bit more
about this funds that you,
that you're proposing as
especially to the venture
capitalist, to the new.
- So I'm not proposing a fund,
I'm proposing a platform of knowledge,
because I remember the
first time we invited
JP Morgan, and Citibank,
and there was a lot of American banks,
but also European banks.
And we did it with the University
of Villapressa, Espania,
Spain, with Susana Malcorra,
that used to be the
Chief of Staff of Ban Ki-moon,
the former secretary-general,
and she was also Minister
for the Affairs of Argentina,
Susanna called me and said,
"How can we work together in this?"
So we decided to create this platform
together with the European Union,
the European Bank of Reconstruction,
but we were talking about
investments that yield
very positive results,
but are products for women
women's lead organizations
or entrepreneurs,
and also services for women.
And I give you an example.
And there, I found by researching
who is who in the financial world,
and why is it that they're
not investing in women?
And I came across with the
first unicorn of the region
and she was called
herself the pink unicorn.
She's little like this,
she's from Argentina,
and she lives in Miami.
So I went to see her and said,
"How did you manage,
to get $1 billion for women's investment?"
And she said, "It was very difficult.
I had to navigate a lot
of sexual harassment.
of, sexual," conversation?
- Bias.
- "Bias from men that
they just wanted to have
dinner or lunch with me,
just for the sake of it.
And it took only one man,
that was a big investor, that realized,
'I hear you. I will invest in you.'
And when he decided, then
it came across many others."
And one of the investments
that was the first investment that,
that she came across was an American,
biotechnology, that she invented,
and most women are gonna
sympathize with me,
a machine to do the mammography,
but with a gender lens.
It's, is a machine that
captures your, your breast,
and you don't have to be squeeze as it is,
which is horrible the way it is,
because of course it was done by a man
(general laughter)
because no women can really
invent a machine like that.
So she decided she decided to create this,
this machine, and also it's mobile,
so it means that you can go
to rural areas and et cetera.
So, you know,
she came with this
investment of $20 million
and this man realized that
this is a money making machine.
So he invested a hundred million dollars.
So the American lady said,
"Oh my God, what I'm gonna do
now with this kind of money?"
So now he, she's producing the machines
and most likely you
will benefit from that.
But this is an example of
a product and a service
that is done with a gender lens.
And it took one man to realize
that we really need to achieve that.
So that's what we are trying to do;
to educate the financial sector,
to understand that they are biases.
And we need a, a test with the IDB,
the Inter-American Development
Bank Research Department.
We send 20 actors and
actresses, 10 men and 10 women,
in Santiago, Chile, to
get a loan from a bank.
The same conditions, everything,
they were young, they were 28
and 20% of women were rejected, the loans,
just because they were women.
And then we realized that the
risk analysts were 99% men.
And the bias was,
"Oh, you are at the age of conception.
Most likely you will be a mother,
so you will not pay me the loan."
Why?
I mean, 99% of the return of debt
women are, are 99% responsible,
much more than men that are 80%.
So these bias, we needed to
explain, we needed to educate.
And of course, when we went to,
we had a meeting with the
presidents of the banks,
they were all men, you know,
and when I presented, I said,
"You lost 6 billion dollars of business
because of the bias."
"What!" they said.
(general laughter)
There you go.
When you have bias,
when you don't understand
the product and service
that women wants to do,
and the fact that women are most likely
more inclined to work as a
network, the sorority of women,
the association compared
to, you know, you name it.
We could be a force of nature.
The energy that women of this region has,
we can be outta poverty very soon.
So this is what we are fighting.
You know, the patriarchy, this bias, this,
these ways of not
understanding the diversity,
how the diversity can help
for the business environment.
So this is what we are trying
to do with this platform.
- Great story María-Noel, the great story.
Any more questions from the
audience, please, we have.
- My name is Mariana.
I'm from School of the Environment,
I'm graduating this year as well,
and I was wondering if within UN Women,
there have been talks about
how to create cultural change,
maybe at the local levels,
in schools, because I think
one of the biggest barriers
for women's empowerment
and women equality in the region
is even when women have the opportunity,
they weren't raised to feel like they,
they were capable of taking those roles
and the men around them
are not encouraging them
to take those roles.
So how, how do we address that?
And in a way that's
respectful to, of course,
to the region and, and
to the current norms,
but building towards a
more equal society for all?
- Thank you for the question.
We are doing it by three things.
We work a lot with UNESCO and with UNICEF,
as well as other UN agencies
that are more in education than us.
We did a pro, we have a
program that is called
Second Chance Education,
in Mexico and in Chile,
those are pilot projects,
financed by a private foundation.
And what we are doing there
is to reach out to those women
that left the education system,
because of what you're saying,
because they were early
mothers, early pregnancies,
and because they were pushed
by their partners to stay home
and because they didn't
have the self-confidence.
So this program is about self-confidence,
it's about rebuilding
the willpower of women,
and most likely those women
are victims of psychological
violence, right?
So we have 2000 women in
Mexico, not in Mexico City,
but in two states, and
what I saw was incredible
because I met them the first day
that we started the program,
nobody dared to talk.
They were crying all the time.
You know, they were, you
know, they were nervous,
and with fear,
what is gonna happen if my
husband sees that I'm here?
And then two years later, I
came to visit the program.
I couldn't believe what I saw, you know,
those women with self-confidence.
"I am an entrepreneur.
I handle the money now.
If he doesn't like it,
he can leave," you know,
(general laughter)
and I say, "Oh my God,
what happened here?"
So by building their self-esteem,
and it's not traditional
education that you want,
but it's the education they need.
And in the pandemic, most of
them lost their entrepreneur,
you know, initiatives,
but they rebuilt others.
And the most important thing that I saw
was the network between indigenous women,
between women that were
discriminated because of their age,
because they were too
young or too old, you know?
So we have to tackle the self-confidence
because that's why it's
been too many centuries
of telling, "You can't do
it because you're a woman.
You can't do it because you're a woman."
So they are, "It's built in your genes!
You can't do it because
you're a woman," you know?
So we have to remake it and
we have to understand that
self-confidence will
take you very far away
and will allow you to be
brilliant in whatever you do.
And I think we are still
in the era of first time,
first time, an astronaut
women that goes to the moon.
First time a woman becomes a unicorn.
First time a woman is president.
So we are still in that era, you know,
so what we need is accelerators.
We need the accelerators
by changing the behavior.
And, to answer your question,
we are using behavioral science.
We are using positive deviance.
We are trying to bring all of the menu of,
of things that are happening
in innovation, not just,
but I think behavioral
science, neu, neuroscience,
it's important to use
it to change community.
And also, and that, that's my last point,
we are working with religious leaders
because religion is part of our life.
And, you know, I realized
by working with religious leaders
of all different religious,
they didn't even know they were
doing their discrimination,
or they didn't even realize
how much harm they were doing to women.
So it was so interesting to
work with Catholic priests,
pastors from different
denominations, Muslims.
We have an enormous network that,
that we work on a regular basis.
And, you know,
they thought that feminist
was about abortion,
or was about, you know,
shouting in the streets
so they didn't realize all these things.
And they say,
"You are right.
We need to respect the dignity of women.
That is every religion,
the dignity of women."
So that's what we are,
and that's why for us
human rights of women are essential
and central to our work.
- I would say, María-Noel,
this is so important,
what you just said.
And of course we're
counting on Yale students.
- Yes.
- Male and female, we're
going to become world leaders.
We're going to get the jobs
to also think about this,
in advance, because it also,
this self-esteem for women
it also is part of being,
looking at role models,
like many of you will be,
and school other women.
And, you know, you're gonna
be working in your countries.
Many of you are from our region.
So I, we are counting on them.
- Yes.
- So I think we have one
more question from Juan,
- the gentleman,
- Juan.
- Thank you so much.
I'm Juan, first year Master's student
in Jackson Institute for
Global Affairs from Colombia
and as well have many questions,
some of which we have
like started to answer,
but I guess my main one is
how does the challenges of
working to empower women
between rural and urban areas changes
because it's still kind of
an urban movement and the
rural ones are even like
in a worse condition,
so how, what are the
difference in the challenges
and how are you like
creating different strategies
to make sure that also like
rural women are empowered properly?
- Thank you for your question.
And yes, it is different,
the objectives in life, but
is also different the context
and the context for equality and diversity
is very important as well.
I would say that in
Colombia, in particular,
after the peace agreements,
we have a hundred provisions
of gender equality
in the peace agreement.
So we are working with women
that were most affected by the conflict.
So, for us, it has been
an amazing opportunity
to realize the leadership that
is emerging in rural areas,
indigenous women, Afro-descendant women.
And their voice will never be shut down.
I can tell you once they started,
they are amazing leaders.
And we have the opportunity,
perhaps we don't know yet,
but there is a very prominent
Afro-descendant leader
that is candidate to be vice president.
And this is the first time that
is happening in the country.
So I hope that, you know,
the rural women have the same
needs as the urban women,
but they've been treated differently.
In the self-esteem, they
need the same things,
in the political participation as well,
and the economic empowerment as well.
And they suffer violence the same.
I think is the intensity and
it's the lack of networks,
and so that's why we need
to push for more networks.
And we need to be more aware,
from the UN in particular,
to these amazing women that
are emerging as leaders
and bring them to the table.
Normally we tend to work
with the urban leaders
because they are the most noisy,
but we need to be caring for
the one that are left behind.
And I see in the region, it's emerging,
a lot of indigenous women,
Afro-descendant women.
We had an amazing leader
in the vice president of Costa Rica.
She's Afro-descendant and in Costa Rica,
you never think that there
is Afro-descendant population
that is a minority, but
is extremely important.
And I think that the more we have,
the more we have to integrate them
and, you know, provide
them with opportunities
of more training or more exposure.
We went to the security council
with the mothers of the Sepur Zarco.
It was a location in
Guatemala where the women were
systematically raped as
an instrument of war.
So we demonstrated,
this is the only case in the world
that by weaponizing the sexual slavery,
the national law condemned the militaries,
it's the first.
So we went to the Security, and
it was only indigenous women
who were telling their story,
in their own language because
they didn't speak Spanish.
So, you know, we are
trying to make role models,
to bring them to the tables
and to the conversations.
You know, that with the pandemic,
we were all the time in Zoom, you know,
but they didn't have technology,
so they didn't have access.
40% of the women in Latin America
they don't have computers,
they don't have access to Internet.
40% and we are talking about, you know,
40% of 300 million.
So, you know, by trying
to listening to them
because they are solution makers
for climate changes adaptation,
climate changes mitigation,
to preserve the biodiversity.
So it is so, so important
to listen to them
and integrate their demands in the,
and also the feminist
movement is very particular
because they don't like young.
They don't like the
young because they said,
"They don't know, they
don't have experience."
Hello. What are you talking about?
So we had a lot of problems
with a traditional feminists.
They didn't want it,
the younger generation.
"They don't have an NGO.
They are movements. They will disappear."
No.
So I have an advisory board
as a Regional Director
and they are so diverse.
This is the first time
they are very diverse
because I brought young, from every,
every intersectionality
and the traditional families say,
"How come I'm not in your board?"
You will never be, (general laughter)
because you don't bring the diversity.
And I need to listen to what are the,
and also I brought one man.
So everybody was indignated.
"How can you bring a man?"
Because we, "They're the solution
to our problems as well."
So I think that we need to
listen to each other much more.
We need to work much more with men
and we need to bring
leaders that are respectful
of the dignity of women no
matter where we come from.
The intersectionality is critical
and human rights are still, you know,
the values that, that we need to defend.
Otherwise, I am not very optimistic
of what is happening in the
region from political side,
but I am very optimistic
with the youth of the region
and of course the women of the region.
- Thank you very much, María-Noel,
for this wonderful talk
of so many important issues
that you have brought.
And especially for showing
here at Yale, how broad,
and how new the gender
and diversity agenda is
and so many topics
that are still on the
table that need to evolve.
I would like, we have literally
two minutes before we,
we cut.
So I would like to ask you,
a final question is, your recommendations
that you would like to
leave the Yale students.
- Yes.
- So many, as you can
tell, they are interested
and I have seen them in
my classes, how engaged,
how interested they are,
how can they contribute to
advance gender and diversity,
not only in our region, in
Latin America and the Caribbean,
but in their own, which
where they're gonna
be moving and working going forward?
- Well, first of all, you are
the leaders of the future,
as Jessica was saying
and I think that you will be
much broader leaders
if you understand the gender dimension
in all the aspects that
we were discussing.
I believe that Yale, as a
fantastic institution it is,
if you do more research on
these matters, if you put your,
you know, your focus on researching these
alternative issues of gender,
because normally academic
focus on human rights,
on public policies, that needs to be done,
that, I would say that, sometimes
the research does not match
what is happening in the region.
So it would be great if
we can have new students
to come more to the region
and to bring the amazing
academic structures
that you are receiving
here to Latin America,
because we still have
very poor universities,
poor in the sense that
we are not modernized.
I see when I talk with students
that they think in a unilateral way.
They are not crossing different frontiers.
And I think that we need to do
much more cross-fertilization work.
Yesterday I have the
privilege to have dinner with
fellow students from Turkey, from Israel,
from Mongolia, from Germany,
and they are doing amazing work.
I was so excited to listen to them.
Thank you very much, for you to,
oh, she's doing our research
on an amazing issue.
Why is it that women in
Turkey are voting conservative
when the conservative
government is pushing women
to be much more conservative?
So there, there is,
there are so many issues
that you guys can have the,
the luxury to research,
being in a, such a
prestigious institution.
So I really would like
to see much more research
being done on these issues,
cross-fertilized on different
regions of the world,
because we are called
the middle-income region,
but we are the most unequal
region in the world.
And we are still with low productivity,
with so much inequality,
how can we get out of this
trap that we are a as a region?
So economic factor, financial
factors, climate changes.
So all these factors, it's
not just gender issues,
it's like how the perspective
of women can be studied there.
And, for me also, it would be an honor,
if we can have some of
youth come into UN Women,
we have offices in many countries,
our regional office is in Panama,
but we have offices in, our
biggest office is in Colombia.
And then we have in
Haiti, in the Caribbean,
in Mexico, Argentina, you name it, Brazil.
So you are much welcome
to come to our offices to
do your research in situ
and that would be great.
So thank you so much for
giving me the opportunity.
And I hope that I put some seed of,
of trying to continue
working in gender issues
but in different dimensions.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much for coming,
(audience applauds)
(indistinct)
(applause continues)
(music chimes softly)